para ucrania no hay posibilidad de
entregar la ciudad portuaria de mariupol
sitiada por las fuerzas rusas la vice
primera ministra ucraniana rechazó la
oferta de moscú no se puede hablar de
ninguna rendición de deponer las armas
ya hemos informado de ello a la parte
rusa el domingo el ministerio de defensa
ruso propuso un ultimátum ofreciendo a
los ucranianos de mariupol un pasto
seguro fuera de la ciudad portuaria de
las fuerzas ucranianas se rinden a las
tropas rusas dando aquí es un plato de
hasta las 5 de la mañana ahora en moscú
prisión para tres de liniers reflexión
crime hacemos un llamamiento a las
unidades de las fuerzas armadas de
ucrania para que cesen las hostilidades
te pongan las armas y por los corredores
humanitarios acordados con la parte
ucraniana entren en los territorios
controlados por kiev
with no pot control ni kilitos desde el
inicio de la guerra mariupol ha sufrido
algunos de los ataques más intensos de
las fuerzas rusas
[Música]
las tropas han rodeado la ciudad durante
más de tres semanas atrapando a los
residentes que están sin acceso a
electricidad agua o gas durante el fin
de semana las tropas rusas entraron en
la ciudad ampliando su bombardeo sobre
mariupol ahora las autoridades
ucranianas dicen que una escuela de arte
donde se refugiaban 400 personas fue
bombardeada intensos combates callejeros
que dificultan la verificación del
número de fallecidos biskupovic tambores
que no había posiciones militares allí
había unas 400 personas allí gente
pacífica en su mayoría mujeres y niños y
personas mayores ahora están bajo los
escombros ponen pizza ual
la cifra actual de muertos en mariupol
es de al menos 2.500 personas aunque es
probable que la cifra real sea mayor si
rusia tomara la ciudad portuaria del
marathón sería una gran victoria
conectándola con las regiones
separatistas prorrusas de túnez y
lugansk